joining us now is carrie severino
president of the judicial crisis network
and former justice thomas supreme court
clerk as was i of course carrie
how much
do these leaks that keep coming i'm
surprised how little this got covered
today in the media really
how much damage is being done to the
court drip drip trip yeah it's like
you're getting a play-by-play of each
individual interaction behind the scenes
this is not as you know this is not all
what it was like when we were there it
used to be that this is the one branch
in
this city that doesn't leak so it's a
huge breach on the court i agree i hope
this person's found quickly i think the
good news is what it sounds like from
this leak is that the justices haven't
shifted i think that's good on a lot of
levels i think it's not too surprising
because this late in the term boy if
they're switching now you know you got
to do a lot of reshuffling and
regretting opinions i think that would
be very unusual uh and i'm glad to see
they haven't caved to the pressure but
as a legal matter what what's a strategy
here do you think i'm trying to figure
out motive you know i always think a
motive and a crime scene is an ethical
uh crime ethical scene what's the motive
here
well i mean a lot of people assume i
assume it's a liberal clerk who thought
you know this is kind of a desperation
move right this is the last ditch effort
we see what's going to happen roe is
going to be overturned by this point in
the term if if someone was going to
change at all which is rare they
probably would have already happened so
i think they thought this is a
last-ditch effort i think it's clearly
going to backfire i mean we're already
seeing it backfiring with the broad um
opposition even among democrats to the
crazy people protesting in front of
justice's houses the refusal of
president biden to say that that needs
is beyond the pale so it's backfiring
and i think if anything it strengthens
the spine of the justices but you know
these are 20-somethings who i think
maybe can't think very far ahead and uh
frankly you know i think it's
coordinated carrie that it's not just
one person i mean i have a number of
friends
who you know probably you haven't talked
to them but it's not just one person
they they believe and they think it's a
coordinated more like you know what
happened with the leak that led to the
controversy over justice thomas's
confirmation hearing well you know
it's just it's still so hard for me to
wrap my brain not even one clerk leaking
in such a ginormous way i mean some of
these other ones saying leaking the
amount of the judges on different things
that's bad enough but the leak of an
entire opinion i don't know if there's
multiple people involved in this that in
theory ought to make it even easier for
the chief justice to track them down
right because it's okay
you and i if you and i or a couple of
other former clerks had all the clerks
in one room it would take us about 10
minutes i'm sorry to find out who the
leaker was i'm sorry we can't group
right and everyone knows everybody else
we all even liberals can we all know
everybody else everyone knows each other
yeah how hard is this
it's where this this just something
about this just doesn't seem right to me
beyond just the leak well this i mean
come on time's a waste and let's find
out who it is or who they are now here's
what jeffrey toobin said today carrie
about our former boss justice clarence
thomas watch
thomas repeatedly has said we should not
honor precedent if we disagree with the
result and so that means he is much more
willing to overturn precedent than other
justices he will now have this
opportunity because the supreme court
today is very much his court
i hope so yeah i hope it is that's great
news if that's the case but your
reaction to that
pejoratively obviously yeah i i i
couldn't agree with that it's the best
thing i've ever heard i mean that's
putting me in a great mood if it's the
thomas court we're in good shape yeah
like i mean a few a few months ago when
someone inadvertently said chief justice
thomas i think that kind of was getting
they were getting uh something which is
he is the intellectual heavyweight on
the court he is the anchor and the
leader of the absolutely in the absence
of uh scalia yeah it was left to tom
absolutely and i think you know we're
seeing that of course news flash none of
the justices always follow precedent the
liberal justice is included but justice
thomas has been very clear you know i
took an oath to uphold the constitution
not what some guy said about it
incorrectly 50 years ago and i think
that's great well it's pretty funny that
the new york times has said well this is
like the leaky branch well it is leaking
now but that it's like it's become so
political we've been saying the court
and their outcomes in certain cases have
been political for what 60 years 50
years so now the new york times doesn't
like political court well that's what
we've we've been saying welcome to the
party exactly kerry great to see you in
studio and remember come on if you can't
watch us live it's not that hard just
hit your little series record on your
dvr your remote whatever so you don't
want to miss us every weeknight at 10 pm
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else